neither new customs duties nor limits on  overseas investments have managed to  halt the rupee's slide India's currency  is recording new lows against the dollar  on an almost daily basis at India's  stock exchange in Mumbai the news pushed  down share prices there are rumors that  india's central bank has intervened to  stem the decline but many traders are  still concerned a deep recession is to  come we have been going down for the  past two three quarters and now our  rupee has touched an ever earlier seen  low so I think this time the recession  is more fundamental more india-centric  recession whereas us have been  progressing and I think it's more  serious and it could be definitely more  troublesome many foreign investors are  reacting to the threat of crisis by  pulling money out of India and urgently  needed economic reforms are making slow  progress